Russell’s back was pressed against the wall, his
shuddering hands gripping the fire axe. The low
emergency lighting filling the corridor indicated
the lockdown was still in effect. Although,
that was simultaneously a blessing and a curse.
Sure, it meant that… thing couldn’t get out,
hopefully. But it also meant that Russell was
stuck in this wing of the facility with it.
He had no idea if anyone else was left. He
hadn’t seen what had happened to Carpenter.
Maybe it got him, or perhaps he had managed
to give it the slip at the last second. There
was no way of knowing for sure. It had
all started so simply, so innocently,
and with such noble intentions. If he had known it
would lead to all this madness, Russell would have
never put his name down on the request form.
The SCP Foundation had been working on a way
to neutralize or cure SCP-610 for what felt like
forever. To one team of scientists, the infamously
so-called Flesh That Hates was a fascinating
organism. It was a highly-contagious Sarkic
skin disease, isolated entirely within a small
area of Siberia. That on its own wasn’t enough
to pique the interest of the research team led by
Doctor Carpenter, including his hand-picked star
Researchers Russell and David, along with their
assistant Clennon and Doctor Bottin, an expert on
infectious diseases who had recently joined their
efforts to provide his specialist knowledge. What
did captivate all of them, however, was what
SCP-610 did when it infected a human being.
The disease would trigger aggressive and
uncontrollable mutations within its infected,
and could virtually rewrite their entire
physiology in a heartbeat. The Flesh That
Hates was capable of transforming a person’s
body into a horrifying, fleshy mass of limbs
and matter that barely resembled a human being
anymore. And in addition, the infected individuals
would retain some level of awareness, attacking
any uninfected person with extreme hostility.
There had long been chatter among some other
research teams studying SCP-610 about devising
a way to weaponize the disease. If they could
somehow create a variant that didn’t turn people
into monsters, or at least caused the fleshy
abominations to die shortly after mutation,
then the Foundation or another interested
party could deploy the Flesh That Hates as
a biological weapon. Doctor Carpenter had
long abhorred the idea, instead searching
for a way to completely reverse the effects of an
SCP-610 infection. It may have been idealistic,
perhaps even naïve by some standards, but
the rest of his team was behind him in the
pursuit of that noble goal. Although not one of
them knew it would soon cost them their lives…
Hitting speed bump after speed bump in their
research, the team were beginning to lose
hope. Researcher David was the most outspoken
in how tired he was of seeing the same results,
yelling in frustration that the Flesh could not
be cured by conventional means. However, it was
that outburst that gave Russell the idea. They
had tried treating SCP-610 like a common virus,
as if it was any other form of disease, largely
thanks to Doctor Bottin’s input. And granted,
that approach had taught them a lot about the
Flesh’s ability to contaminate a subject from
a single cell. But this infection
was anomalous through and through,
could the solution to eradicating it for good
lie not in a medical cure, but in another SCP?
Russell brought this hypothesis to the rest of the
research team, and each of them had suggestions
for other anomalies they could potentially
use to cure a subject of the Flesh That Hates.
“We could get SCP-049 to take a look at
an infected patient,” Clennon suggested.
“Might work,” Carpenter mused.
“Although even if he cures someone,
he might also kill them. He has his whole deal
about ridding the world of ‘The Pestilence’,
could prove to be a problem.”
“There’s always 682,” David
said dryly. “Have the Reptile eat up all the
SCP-610 infectees, and viola. Problem solved.”
“Oh, real helpful, David,” Researcher Russell
retorted. “And what are we going to do when
SCP-682 adapts to the Flesh? You really want
an infected, immortal lizard on the loose?”
“Gentlemen, please,” Doctor Bottin spoke
up. “We’re forgetting one obvious option.
I propose we submit a joint formal request
to use SCP-914 for this experiment.”
Unanimously, the group all agreed that this
was the best course of action. SCP-914,
or ‘The Clockworks’, was a giant machine with two
booths marked ‘Input’ and ‘Output’. Although the
Foundation still couldn’t fully comprehend exactly
how, SCP-914 seemed to take any object placed
within it and disassemble, recreate, improve or
destroy the item depending on its current setting.
There was one issue, however. A prior
failed experiment wherein a D Class was
placed in SCP-914 had led to some pretty
disastrous consequences. As a result,
ever since no organic matter was to be placed
within the Clockworks; a rule that the team’s
experiment with the Flesh would breach. Still,
they pressed on, each of the five researchers
signing their request to utilize SCP-914 before
it was submitted to the Foundation higher-ups.
Within hours, the request was denied. But the team
were determined that SCP-914 could be the key to
solving the Foundation’s long-standing issue with
SCP-610. Doctor Carpenter repealed the decision,
urging the higher-ups to reconsider their
decision. He argued that this flouting of
the ‘no organic matter’ rule was necessary to
potentially rid the world of the Flesh That Hates.
After a few further days of consideration,
the request was finally, fatefully granted…
The team went to work immediately,
requisitioning two test subjects,
both of which had suffered SCP-610 infections
and were horribly mutated. The pair of them
were deemed a potential hazard to every member
of Foundation staff on-site, and as a result,
the entire wing of the facility where the
Clockworks was housed had to be evacuated
for safety. Dressed in biohazard suits to
protect themselves, the researchers used an
electric cattle prod to coax the first Flesh
specimen into the Input chamber of SCP-914.
This was the test run, they wanted to see if the
Clockworks would actually be able to affect those
infected with SCP-610 at all. Plus, they needed
a failsafe just in case something went wrong,
and luckily the machine had just the thing.
Russell asked Clennon to set the Clockworks
to ‘Rough’, and with a click and whir of its
numerous gears and gyros, SCP-914 came to life.
Instantly, the infected test subject was
completely obliterated. The setting had
reduced it to atoms, disintegrating it on
such a microscopic level that there was
nothing left in the Output chamber. The second
infected creature seemed to bristle with anger,
but didn’t attack or become aggressive as
it too was prodded towards the Clockworks.
Next, perhaps out of fear that their theory might
be wrong, the team agreed to set SCP-914 to its
‘1:1’ setting. Sure enough, the machine recreated
another instance of a specimen infected with the
Flesh That Hates, replacing the previous one.
“We all know we’re stalling,” Researcher David
piped up. “Let’s do what we came here
for, set the Clockworks to ‘Coarse’.”
Nervously, receiving a nod from Doctor Carpenter,
Clennon stepped forward to switch the dial on
SCP-914 to the Coarse setting. This was the
primary reason the team had all agreed to use the
machine on a Flesh specimen; this setting could
disassemble any item placed in the Input booth,
separating it into its base components. Bottin had
suggested the use of SCP-914 based on the theory
that, if this worked correctly, the Clockworks
could extract the Flesh That Hates from its
infected host, rendering them free of the disease.
The machine made a colossal amount of noise
as Clennon hurried back to a safe distance
with the others. But as it was powering up,
seconds from activating, Doctor Carpenter noticed
something. The color drained from his face as he
saw it; none of the others had noticed from
a distance that the dial hadn’t been set to
Coarse. Instead, it pointed to ‘Very Fine’,
the highest refinement setting SCP-914 had.
“What the hell have you done?” Carpenter yelled
at Clennon, before the machine suddenly activated.
What stepped free from the Output booth
stunned the researchers. It was a man,
a seemingly-ordinary human, who had presumably
been infected by SCP-610 some time ago. He stepped
nervously out of the machine, looking confused
for a moment as a pair of Foundation security
guards cautiously approached him.
“We did it,” Russell said in awe.
Suddenly, fleshy tendrils burst forth from
the man’s arms, latching onto the approaching
guards. They screamed in agony, their bodies
melting, becoming a bloody, misshapen mass
that stayed attached to the humanoid creature at
the center. It was like they became a part of it,
the guards’ arms and legs forming additional limbs
as their forms were reconstituted and repurposed
as part of a monster… that was now crawling
on its six legs towards the research team.
In a blind panic, the group scrambled for the
entrance, the head of the infected man splitting
open down the middle, opening up into a wide,
snapping pair of jaws. Panting so hard as he
ran that his breath fogged up the clear faceplate
of his hazard suit, Russell ran through the door,
hearing someone close it behind. He stopped
for a moment, looking back to see the creature
on the other side of the door, starting to
spill through the doorframe like a liquid.
Running faster around a corner, Russell
came to another halt in the common area,
a third security guard following just before a
thick, steel security door came slamming down,
sealing the creature on the other side.
“The other door didn’t even hold it. What good
is that going to do?” Researcher David yelled.
“More to the point,” Doctor Carpenter said,
turning and marching towards Clennon.
He launched a furious punch at the
Assistant, knocking him to the floor.
“Why did you set SCP-914 to Very Fine,
Clennon?” the enraged doctor shouted. “You’re the
one who unleashed that abomination, you maniac!”
“What?” Clennon replied, fearfully
trembling. “I didn’t, I swear I didn’t!
It said ‘Coarse’, I’m sure of it!”
“You expect us to believe that was
a mistake?” Carpenter roared.
“Gentlemen, we need to focus on
the situation at hand,” the security officer
interjected. “Regardless of who’s responsible,
we need to inform the Foundation higher ups.”
“There’s an emergency lockdown,” Russell
replied. “It would have triggered the
moment the SCP-610 specimen got free.”
“You’ve trapped us with a monster,
Clennon!” Doctor Carpenter spat.
“Hold on,” Researcher David spoke up. “Wasn’t it
Bottin’s idea to use SCP-914 in the first place?”
The common area fell silent as everyone
turned to look at Doctor Bottin.
“Did you plan for this, doc?” David pushed.
Taking off his glasses, Bottin chuckled.
“Need I remind you, my friends, that
we all agreed to use the Clockworks,
did we not? All of our names are on the
request,” he answered. “Besides, accusing me,
David? That’s rather rich coming from you.”
“What’s that supposed to mean?”
the researcher fired back.
Beckoning his finger, Bottin encouraged
the rest of the team to follow him across the
common area, to where a row of lockers stood,
each door bearing one of their names.
He gestured to the one labelled ‘David’.
“Go on,” Bottin added.
Shooting him a dirty look, David barged
past the disease expert and opened his locker. Not
one among the group expected what would fall out:
it was an old, leather-bound book, symbols carved
into its front cover. Instantly, thanks to their
work studying SCP-610, the researchers all knew
a text on Sarkicism when they saw one. It had
long been known that the Flesh That Hates was
often described in texts revered by Sarkic cults,
who worshiped death, decay, and disease.
“What the hell, David?” Russell exclaimed,
picking up the book and examining it in disbelief.
“You’re a Sarkist?” Carpenter asked, the fury
in his voice already elevating.
“No, I’m not!” Researcher David
protested. “I’ve never seen that before!”
“It was in your locker!” the doctor yelled.
“You’re one of those cannibal cultists!
This was your plan? To refine the Flesh
for your twisted death-worshipping religion?”
“It certainly seems that way,” Bottin interjected.
“After all, Researcher David did seem frustrated
at our earlier results. Impatient, even.”
“You!” David pointed at the doctor.
“You planted this in my locker!”
“Y-you’re a Sarkist,” Clennon repeated in
a nervous stammer. “You made me turn the
dial to Very Fine, you made that thing
appear… you made me your accomplice!”
Angered tears streaming down his face, Clennon’s
hand reached for the security officer’s gun and
went to draw it, planning to shoot David on the
spot. But as he went to pull the weapon from the
guard’s holster, it wouldn’t budge. It was then
that Assistant Clennon stared in horror at his
hand; his fingers had fused to the guard’s leg.
The officer gave a twisted grin as his torso
burst open, tendrils of flesh latching on to
Clennon and assimilating him. Just like it had
done before, the Flesh creature broke down its
victim’s body, making it a new part of itself,
a grotesque mass of limbs and bloody matter,
littered with the discarded faces of those
it had infected. The research team looked
at it terrified, their stomachs turning,
disgusted at the growing, growling
abomination of bodies fused to one another.
“Oh, you’re beautiful,” Russell heard a voice
whisper behind him; he turned to see Bottin,
looking at the SCP-610 creature and smiling.
Researcher David was the closest, and the creature
lunged at him, pulling his leg out from under
him. Screaming in fear, the researcher fell onto
the ground and was dragged towards the Flesh. It
pulled him in, his body stretching, skin tearing
and bones snapping as he became part of it, a
new set of limbs added to the monster. Doctor
Carpenter went to try and pull him free, but it
was already too late, and he stepped back; knowing
that, if he touched it, he’d be infected too.
The sound of running caught Russell’s attention,
and he spotted Bottin making a break for
it. Grabbing Doctor Carpenter by the sleeve,
the researcher pulled him in the same
direction, partly running away from the
Flesh as it assimilated David, and partly
chasing the Sarkic saboteur. The pair of
them quickly caught up to Bottin, leaning
over himself and panting breathlessly.
“Thank god you two made it,” he wheezed after
the run. “I can’t believe David could do this,
to unleash this… nightmare on us.”
Russell thought to snap at him, to scream
how dare he keep lying. But Bottin’s back was to
him now, he’d never get a better chance. There was
a cabinet on the corridor wall, containing a fire
axe for emergencies. As carefully and quietly as
he could, Russell fished the axe out of its case,
whilst Bottin and Carpenter were looking away.
“We should get the Foundation to lift
the lockdown,” Bottin was saying. “They
need to let us out and then- AAHH!”
He let out a blood-curdling scream
mid-sentence as the axeblade wounded him. Russell
pulled it back, standing over the doctor as he
fell to the floor in agony.
“Russell, have you lost
your mind!” Carpenter exclaimed.
“No, doctor. He’s the cultist, I have no idea
how he tricked Clennon, but that Flesh creature
exists because of him,” the researcher answered.
From the floor, unable to move thanks to
his injury, Doctor Bottin began to laugh.
“It took me years to infiltrate the Foundation,
so much time spent waiting to gain access to the
blessed Flesh!” he gloated. “And now, you’ve
helped me to refine it, to create its ultimate
form. You want to kill me? Go ahead, Russell.
My life doesn’t matter. For once that creature
is free, it will bring about a new age of
Flesh! And Grand Karcist Ion will reward me
for the role I played in unleashing it!”
“David was right,” Carpenter realized.
“Bottin, you… you planted that
book on him to throw us off.”
“Doctor, we need to think of something,”
Researcher Russell interjected, axe still
in hand. “Nobody knows more about the Flesh That
Hates than us, there must be a way to kill that
thing. Otherwise, if it gets out of this lockdown,
it could spread to everyone in the Foundation.
What about fire? That’s been effective
against SCP-610 infectees before, right?”
“Yes, yes, but…” the doctor desperately tried
to think. “This new being we’ve created-”
“He created,” Russell argued, looking
at the grinning, wounded Bottin.
“We cannot deny the role we all played
in this, Researcher!” Carpenter argued.
“And we have no idea if it possesses the same
weaknesses as the Flesh before its refinement.”
“But we have to try, sir!”
the researcher protested.
“Of course. I agree.”
***
The sickening sound of a slithering, slick mass
was rapidly approaching. Still laying on the
floor in pain, Doctor Bottin had been dragged
to the middle of a junction, with Carpenter and
Russell hiding around either corner. Suddenly,
Bottin started hollering as the Flesh came
into view, practically calling it to him.
“Oh, look at you!” he exclaimed. “You’re
better than could have ever hoped for!”
Looking down at him with the faces it
had collected, the creature stabbed one of
its disgusting appendages through Bottin,
drawing his body into its growing form.
“I am honored to give my life so that
the age of Flesh may begin,” the doctor said
weakly through the pain as he was infected.
From around the corner, Carpenter had taken the
Sarkic text and set its pages on fire with his
cigarette lighter. Turning to the creature, he
hurled the mass of burning paper at it, hoping it
would be enough fire to spread to the Flesh while
it was assimilating Bottin, who they had left
there as bait. The fiery book collided with the
monstrosity; as Russell peeked around his corner,
he saw the Flesh retreating from the flames,
Bottin’s body now added to it. For a moment,
it seemed like the creature was afraid of
the fire, but slowly it drew nearer and
nearer to the book. With ease, it stamped
on the flames with Bottin’s leg, dousing
the fire and suffering no damage to it at all.
Gripping the axe in his hands. Russell went to
charge at the creature, only to feel something
push him back. Doctor Carpenter had stopped him.
“Run!” he yelled.
Instantly, Russell turned and raced down the
corridor, the sound of fleshy tentacles whipping
through the air. He dared not look back, just in
case the monster was right behind him. Eventually,
he reached another corner and slammed his back
against it, hands shuddering as he held on to
the fire axe. He had no idea what had happened
to Carpenter. Maybe it got him, or perhaps he had
managed to give it the slip at the last second.
“Russell!” came a hushed voice from around
the corner, one the researcher recognized.
He turned to see Doctor Carpenter approaching him,
sneaking like he was trying to avoid being heard.
“I think I managed to give it
the slip!” the doctor whispered.
For a second, Russell backed up, his hands
tightening around the axe handle. This might
have looked like Doctor Carpenter, but was it?
“Are you really… you, doctor?” he asked.
“Of course, I am!” Carpenter replied. “You
don’t think that… I’m not that monstrosity!”
Russell raised the axe defensively, only
to notice the sadness in the doctor’s
face. Unable to bring himself to swing,
even to find out, the researcher lowered
his weapon. Carpenter looked grateful.
“Come on, let’s get them to lift this
lockdown,” he said. “I’m sure an MTF can
step in and take care of our mistake.”
As the pair of them cautiously made their
way towards one of the locked doors,
Doctor Carpenter reached out a hand
to place it on Russell’s shoulder…
Now go and check out “SCP-610 - The Flesh
That Hates” and “SCP-610 Tale - Aftermath”
to experience more unspeakable
horrors of the tainted flesh!